c'est encore plus dur de soi reveillez
vous pensé quand on est une actrice bah
oui parce qu'on n'arrête pas de vous
regardez donc quelle est la meilleure
thérapie contre le temps qui passe par
la chirurgie esthétique en tout cas en
avant la chirurgie esthétique dont mais
j'ai vu les images et elle a du talent
de madonna
ça ma folle ça me fait peur je me dis
mais comment elle se regarde dans le
miroir le matin donc au moins je peux
pas je vais pas tellement me regarde et
à dire je vais pas vraiment aller voir
le moniteur là ouais c'est pas la peine
je je je sais où doit être la lumière et
tant pis ça sera ce que ça sera
le cas de madonna regardez ça c'est ma
basse et madonna reine madonna alors
voilà c'est pas donald à
moi aussi je suis passé au filtre à
l'âme ils filtrent sur la gueule mais qu
il comprend des photos là on comprend
rien
aux producteurs une émission m'a vendu
on n'a pas donné avant après chercher
parce qu'il
fait des vidéos elle a pas de filtre où
elle mais ça aurait très près de
l'objectif et là c'est vrai qu'elle fait
13 par cci sont six
mois je suis un peu d'accord avec
patrice si ça lui fait plaisir c'est
chez ben oui ça fait plaisir moi je suis
passé un truc que je ne sais pas c'est
pas ma culture et puis moi je toucherai
jamais tant pis je préfère avoir mais
franchement si ça leur fait plaisir oui
mais là aussi plein qui sait très bien
fait mais ça ne se voit pas c'est à dire
qu'en fait on remarque que celle où
c'est outrageant ou vraiment c'est
flagrant mais y'en a plein de femmes
plein d'actrice plein de deux chanteuses
qui font de la médecine esthétique et de
la chirurgie esthétique et ça ne se voit
pas parce que c'est bien fait je veux
dire comment j'en mangeais si tu veux te
décourager de faire un chirurgien
esthétique tu vas aller sur google et tu
veux regarder une actrice que j'ai connu
moi c'est qu'à l'époque nous avaient
suivi en tournée elle était qu un
chanteur mais je peux pas dire lequel
des crises qui s'appelait sydney romain
j'étais magnifique sublime si tu vois ce
qu'elle est devenue ces roms c'est un as
ou une photo sépia tôt sur google que tu
verras c'est l'émotion chez eux ce qui
est arrivé alors rome c'est eux
aimeraient
en relation ne pouvait pas imaginer je
suis pas d'accord avec patrick à propos
de madonna vous dit si ça lui fait
plaisir mais oui mais madonna c'est un
exemple lors emilion des dizaines de
millions de jeunes donc l'exemple
qu'elle montre ses se déformer se faire
du mal etc mais plus ce soir tu veux ça
ce n'est pas le feu
ils savent pas qui c'est moi
alors oui une usine au delà de madonna
il ya plein de femmes de 60 ans qui se
sentent pas forcément bien aussi bien
que carole bouquet qui ont besoin de
flash de faire cesser un bénéfice
psychologique et là où il ya une forme
d'hypocrisie c'est qu'il ya plein de
gens qui ont réagi à ça qu'on dit mais
oui mais elle fait de la médecine
esthétique effet les injections donc
voilà une forme d'hypocrisie là dedans
et moi je trouve ça bien si ça peut
aider les gens à se sentir mieux et il
faudra des gens souvent les femmes
malgré tout avec lui donc sur le papier
pour les femmes c'est quand même
terrible bon alors on yatma ci s'ils
n'arrêtent pas de dire les femmes à
partir de 50 ans vous êtes des vieux
croûtons mec qui nous forme dessus ouais
mais on en parle beaucoup moins pour les
autres je travaille à gré tout madrid au
meilleur de nous mêmes comme on dit que
les hommes se bonifie les femmes ne dis
pas que c'est son vrai nom oui j'en
apprenais regarderions à la haine et à
péaule à la caisse qu'elle a pris encore
plus pour carole bouquet qui a été une
des plus belles femmes du monde qui
était au james bond girl et tout ça
effectivement elle dit qu'elle ne
supporte plus de se voir parce que les
gens lui renvoie perpétuellement les
gens la pression la société de matériel
étaient savons donc là un moment donné
bon bain bardot quoi faut pas que ça
rend alors à les toucher je me vois pas
en quoi que ce soit ce qui arrive ça
se voit bien
regarder
que les films j'en fais ça c'était elle
genève si vous avez la photo d'après
énorme et c'est un mauvais gardien qui
est pire que ça ah oui ok encore pire
quand on aime bien rencontrer sophie non
mais c'est un peu lassé des trucs raté
un
passé bien fait par exemple après que
chez nous on a perdu la diane fondeurs
et
l'argentine la croatie
a condamné ces violences
si vous validez vie rendues à lui en
fait moi je n'ai pas de la chirurgie
esthétique mais moi j'ai aucun problème
à dire que je fais de la matinée cette
île je fais un lien du pottok ce jeu
fait d'acide hyaluronique aux jeunes bah
oui mais justement latine alors dit que
le botox est quelque chose qu'on commet
très vite aux jeunes pour pour s'asseoir
préventif vraiment un faux pas
diaboliser la chose je pense qu'il faut
quand même rester un peu neutre et pas
toujours prendre les exemples extrêmes
comme ça je dois me suis pas contre le
fait avec toi non vraiment et on peut
faire un truc moi oui on touche à un tir
parfait de nom c'est ça s'arrête ma mère
n'arrête non mais ça en vrai quoi c'est
bien de ça va
pas nous refaire un coup sans la barbe
non non non la barre s'est fait
filmer ces travaux la barre un cheval
borgella je fais j'enlève la barbe
ressemble à daniela
[Applaudissements]